let's get to some audience questions
Eddie wrote the first one Eddie says hey
what's a common known debunked hoax that
you still meet people who believe that
it is real one that came to mind is
cracking knuckles I kind of cracked my
knuckles pretty frequently and they're
growing up there will always be someone
every couple years who would say you
know when you crack your knuckles it
causes arthritis and it causes your hand
to swell and there's actually a guy who
for something like 50 years crack the
knuckles only on one hand and after that
point he was tested for sort of mobility
as well as size and no cracking on one
hand cracking for 50 years or something
crazy on the other hand no difference in
mobility and no swelling or difference
in size at all I don't think it's the
best habit though I mean I do be
yourself as well but that about well
it's just one it's kind of annoying to
other people but also I remembered not
being able to crack my knuckles when I
was younger yeah and then as I started
doing it more and more now I can just
crack them all the time right yeah I
know that that does that does happen
yeah but I don't think that that's a
reason I mean it being annoying to other
people I don't know that that's a good
reason to do it or not do it I guess it
depends what kind of relationships you
want to have with the people around you
I don't know but that's never it never
been an impediment to me I I do I mean
this is some people will not like this
but specific religious stories I still
am I'm meeting people that believe them
right like Noah's Ark jesus is coming
back any day pick whatever you want
right when I meet people that literally
believe those things to me it's a little
bit weird to be quite honest and then
vaccines cause autism right I mean we
get emails from people even though it's
been widely debunked I still get emails
from people with links to obscure blogs
or strange YouTube videos and they are
convinced that no just back scenes cause
autism period the people are still out
there I think a lot of these appeal to a
sense of fear or a sense of wonder maybe
like I remember one day I heard that
your blood is actually blue until you
get a cut or something I was exposed to
oxygen and yeah turns red that's
obviously not true I think they just see
those charts the veins and some of them
are seen as blue so maybe your blood is
actually blue too I assumed that it was
just a much darker red that
some people look blueish but I know I
didn't literally think that your blood
was blue until exposed to oxygen I don't
know but that's that's an interesting
one yeah and another one maybe that you
swallow eight spiders per year that's
not true right
not sure no it's 12 everybody knows that
well to us 12 12 or more spiders no but
I I think though that it is true that
you do I mean when I'm biking I seem to
swallow two or three mosquitoes or bugs
of different kinds just through my open
mouth I'm not allowed to because I'm
vegan I know yeah so you don't do that
what you know that's actually a funny
thing my girlfriend is is pescetarian
does a fly count as what it's not
seafood right so if we're biking and a
pescetarian or a vegan accidentally eats
a bug what do you do well I mean I guess
there's no intent there so you're not
morally responsible for it so you're
applying the same laws to your veganism
as Jews apply to kosher foods like if
someone tricks you into eating pork you
had no intent to eat pork so technically
you've not sinned I guess absolved from
any controversy
yeah interesting okay and then just
general conspiracy theories I guess I
would add right I mean there's a lot of
conspiracy theories I don't have to name
them we don't have to go through every
single one of them but there's lots of
conspiracy theories that I'm still
shocked that people believe and there's
a whole show dedicated to this you can
check out myth busters and they have
done hundreds of them maybe yeah and
some of those are conspiracies and some
are more like these right common sense
things that are not really common sense
of any kind although it's been years
since I've watched that show like
throwing a penny over the Empire State
Building will that kill someone what
hits the ground yes I gotta watch the
show to find out my recollection is that
the penny if it could not flip it all
and fall straight down it could go fast
enough to really hurt someone but that
in practical terms if you toss a penny
off the Empire State Building because it
will sort of tumble naturally it will
not achieve any kind of speed that would
actually hurt someone is that true I
just thought that the terminal velocity
of it wasn't to a point where I was
actually lethal Oh like it may actually
hurt but it wouldn't kill you well
that's a much more reasonable
explanation yeah so anyway these are
some of mine send in some of the ones
you're still talking to people about and
if you saw my email you'd see lots of
them that's for sure